hey what is up guys my PhD here and
welcome to another update video the last
update video I did was update 10.2 which
was when I broke my hand sixteen
stitches a plate and six screws later
we're all good so it's crunch time for
me right now there's always that time of
year for a college student so really any
student where things get a little bit
ridiculous and this seven or eight nine
day stretch for me right now is that
time of year so I'm really busy but I
didn't want to leave you without
anything so I actually did an AMA on
reddit a couple of days ago so if you
don't know what reddit is or what an AMA
stands for it's asking me anything
where in text people can basically ask
you a question about whatever topic they
want whatever they want so I did
actually answer as many questions as I
could and at this moment it is one of
the top 100 most upvoted AMAs of all
time actually right above internet
explorer so I answered a few hundred
questions about YouTube about life about
tech about gadget recommendations about
tech this time of year all sorts of
things like that so if you want to read
it or you feel like you're gonna get
anything out of it you might enjoy it so
I'll leave that as the first link where
I reload that like button so a little
update on the Nexus 6 wireless charging
I mentioned in my review video I
couldn't get it to charge update I have
gotten it to charge but it's just
extremely picky about exactly where you
place it on the charger you have to put
it exactly two-and-a-half inches above
the bottom of the phone and that has to
make contact with the center of the
charging dock and you might not use this
exact charging dock but basically
because the back of the Nexus is so
rounded it doesn't stay in place and
there are no magnets so you really have
to be careful about where you place it
to get it to charge overall not quite as
easy or intuitive as the Magnus where on
the back of the Nexus 5 the 64 gigabyte
sandstone black oneplus one for whatever
reason really does not age very well
basically because of this sandstone
black material it gathers some scratches
over time that really are difficult to
remove and if you want 64 gigabytes you
have to go sandstone black so it's kind
of a tough call to go between the
much less wear and tear showing white
version for 32 gigs or go with that
sandstone black for 64 your call update
on the metal version of the Moto 360 it
is sweet it's really well built and it's
actually a little bit heavier of course
than the leather version I was using
before but also you have to go into a
store and get the size adjusted like a
normal watch if it doesn't fit you with
this amount of links out the box so
otherwise it is an extremely nice watch
and I would highly recommend it if
you're looking for something with a more
premium feel the 13 inch retina macbook
pro that was painted by color wear is
still in really great shape there aren't
any visible Nicks or scuffs or wearing
thin of the paint anywhere on the
machine and that's good to hear because
if you're gonna pay a good chunk of
money to get a custom paint job like
this you want to know that it'll last
you and so far it has the sony xperia z3
compact is the best compact smartphone
you can buy of 2014 I've had it for a
month or so and I've used it a lot and I
haven't done a full review of it yet but
that is upcoming the Droid turbo is the
best phone you can get in a Verizon
store right now so if you're Verizon
customer and you have any doubts about
where to go what to get you cannot go
wrong with the Droid turbo that review
is also in the works the Nexus 9 the
Android tablet I've waited so long for
sort of a hybrid in-between the Nexus 10
the big 10 inch tablet and the Nexus 7
the more compact 7-inch tablet it has
front facing speakers a high resolution
display Android 5.0 and a few
interesting quirks that review is also
in the works now if you have any other
suggestions for things that you would
like to see on video and they can be not
phones or tablets in fact that's
encouraged feel free to leave them in
the comments section below especially
since it's the holiday season gift
guides are a possibility things like
that so if you see stuff you like in the
comments section below that you also
want to see on video give it a thumbs up
and we'll figure out what the next
videos would be in this awesome time of
year also at the time that I'm recording
this video right now the mkbhd channel
has 1.99 million subscribers that's a
lot of people and it's about to be 2
million so hi new people welcome to the
channel I hope you enjoy what's been
going on and what is about to be
uploaded I hope you enjoy the videos and
welcome aboard just getting started with
this stuff so I got to get back to
writing these essays I will be back on
the internet shortly
feel free to follow me on Twitter if you
want to also leave suggestions
what to do next but I'm gonna go right
thank you for watching and I'll talk to
you guys in the next one peace